because the second thing I want to say
about you the last compliment okey-dokey
and then when I rip you apart
cool lamb chop [ __ ] you all right lady
the second thing I wanted to say is is
that like my teeth are very they are
very white but listen this is let's
suppose this is you okay
and it doesn't matter who it the size
doesn't matter but you and steel Vaughn
come from from from MTV right yeah yeah
so in the night so you you know you guys
you're young people attractive people
and your honor
an empty of anything usually when that
occurs it's over after yeah right yeah
you me you know I just saw a Jersey show
reunion me too I love that yeah but I
will yeah yeah but you know it's but
that's pretty much yeah they can't
they're not gonna be able to shake
they're called lifers we call them
lifers the ones that go back oh yeah do
hosting or whatever which is fine it's a
gig to be on a show like that and to
step out of it and to reinvent yourself
and then you come into a different scene
but legitimately
like these two I know you're friends
with you oh I know him we're not Bros oh
I met him a couple times when we did the
shows I've seen well aside from that
like I'm not gonna bring but you then
[ __ ] you but you for you to do a show
like that and to reinvent yourself to
become a legitimate like you literally
are like if you go up to anybody I did I
hate kissing your ass my [ __ ] that
that's so embarrassing I don't I don't
know what to do with it well just to sit
there and you have to look at me
I know make it quick no I would know I
would need to milk it to make her feel
comfortable because of what she said
about me [ __ ] flat [ __ ] row I'm
uncomfortable Gilbert its uptake
Somerville thank you yeah and that's two
compliments and that's pretty much thank
you all the columns have more but it's
actually stupidity on my part that I
didn't utilize but but not the fame or
but whatever the the wave of that yeah
to become a stand-up like I totally was
such an idiot I could have gotten booked
in clubs being a feature act right away
I know and I would have been bad in the
long run but I started from scratch and
I probably should have been smarter no
the way you did it everything the hard
way though you do everything the right
way thing the hard way because I can I
tell you why can I tell you why because
I'm not dumbest person I wait I just
anyways go ahead yeah you're so intense
right now you have you have two kids I
have two children right I know you're
married with you know Tom I know I've
been to your house yes a beautiful house
in that yeah don't don't say where I
[ __ ] live where where where the fire
happened is that that's pretty broad
it's close right yeah I wouldn't even I
don't even know exactly the town that
you live in so relax
[Music]